[Music]
what does marcellus wallace look like
what
what country you from what watch what
ain't no country i ever heard of they
speak english and what we have looked at
the best movies from the 1980s and now
we're moving on to the 1990s shawshank
redemption unforgiven pulp fiction the
list goes on and on and these 90s movies
are certified fresh all repping 10 years
of cinema that upended the biz you take
the blue pill
the story ends
you wake up in your bed and believe
whatever you want to believe
you take the red pill you stay in
wonderland
and i show you how deep the rabbit hole
goes our selections cross the era's
cultural checkpoints including the
american independent golden era
animation renaissance and the full
maturation of a tours like scorsese and
spielberg under the studio system not to
mention the same studios pumped out big
star-driven crass comedies and effects
driven blockbusters so let's count down
the best movies of the 1990s
[Music]
number 10 saving private ryan
captain john miller takes his men behind
enemy lines to find private james ryan
whose three brothers have been killed in
combat surrounded by the brutal
realities of war while searching for
ryan each man embarks upon a personal
journey and discovers their own strength
to triumph over an uncertain future with
honor decency and courage starring tom
hanks edward burns tom sizemore and
directed by steven spielberg critics say
anchored by another winning performance
from tom hanks steven spielberg's
unflinchingly realistic war film saving
private ryan virtually redefines the
genre
oh my god i trust in me
let me not be ashamed
let not my enemies triumph over me
it's got blood on it
number nine boys in the hood
trey is sent to live with his father
furious styles in tough south central
los angeles although his heart-nosed
father instills proper values and
respect in him and his devout girlfriend
brandy teaches him about faith trey's
friends joe boy and ricky don't have the
same kind of support and they're drawn
into the neighborhood's booming drug and
gang culture with increasingly tragic
results starring lawrence fishburne ice
cube cuba gooding jr and directed by
john singleton critics say well-acted
and thematically rich boys in the hood
observes black america with far more
depth and compassion than many of the
like-minded films its success inspired
so do you want to go still for me man
get some corn man
that's the one she told to go get it
show what people get
seeing my wife now right
might as well be y'all got a family
tecmo ball playing up
your wife that's why you got a baby
laugh hey man big on my face all right
mama's boy
let him fight him
brenda ricky don't pull out his fight
hey
cut that out
get off of it
number eight unforgiven
when prostitute delilah is disfigured by
a pair of cowboys in big whiskey wyoming
her fellow brothel workers posed a
reward for their murder but sheriff
little bill daggett who doesn't allow
vigilantism in his town is not happy
about it two groups of gunfighters one
led by aging former bandit william money
the other by the floored english bob
come to collect the reward clashing with
each other and the sheriff starring gene
hackman morgan freeman richard harris
and clint eastwood who also directed the
film critics say as both director and
star clint eastwood strips away decades
of hollywood varnish applied to the wild
west and emerges with a series of
harshly eloquent statements about the
nature of violence and unforgiven
what's this for snakes and such
yeah
we don't have any snakes in here mr
hendershot
ain't depot
god is what
you see mr beauchamp
this is the kind of trash
you find this kind in all saloons all
your prosperous communities
wichita
over in
cheyenne
but you won't find him in the town of
big whiskey
number seven goodfellas
a young man grows up in the mob and
works very hard to advance himself
through the ranks he enjoys his life of
money and luxury but is oblivious to the
horror that he causes a drug addiction
and a few mistakes ultimately unravel
his climb to the top starring robert de
niro ray liotta joe pesci and directed
by martin scorsese critics say
hard-hitting and stylish goodfellas is a
gangster classic and arguably the high
point of martin scorsese's career what
do you do
what what do you do i'm in construction
i don't feel like you're in construction
i'm a union delegate
and now ladies and gentlemen the
copacabana is proud to present the king
of the one-liners
penny
[Music]
[Applause]
are you all i'm youngman to be here
take my wife please
[Applause]
i take my wife everywhere but she finds
her way home
i said where do you want to go for your
anniversary she said i want to go
somewhere i've never been before i
should try the kitchen
dr welzer was here wonderful doctor gave
you guys six months to live couldn't be
number six groundhog day
weatherman phil is out to cover the
annual emergence of the groundhog from
its hole he gets caught in a blizzard
that he didn't predict and finds himself
trapped in a time warp he's doomed to
relive the same day over and over again
until he gets it right starring bill
murray andy mcdowell chris elliott and
directed by harold ramis critics say
smart sweet and inventive groundhog day
highlights murray's dramatic gifts while
still leaving plenty of room for laughs
you're not a god you can take my word
for it this is 12 years of catholic
school talking
i could come back if you're not ready
how do you know i'm not a god
oh please how do you know because it's
not possible
dorks
this is doris her brother-in-law carl
owns this diner she's worked here since
she was 17. more than anything else in
her life she wants to see paris before
she dies oh boy would i what are you
doing this is debbie kleiser and her
fiance fred do i know you they're
supposed to be getting married this
afternoon but debbie is having second
thoughts what
lovely ring
this is bill he's been a waiter for
three years since he left penn state and
had to get work he likes the town he
paints toy soldiers and he's gay
i am
this is gus he hates his life here he
wishes he stayed in the name well i
could have retired on half pay after 20
years
excuse me this is some kind of trip well
maybe the real god uses tricks
number five fargo
fargo is a reality-based crime drama set
in minnesota in 1987. jerry is a car
salesman in minneapolis who has gotten
himself into debt and is so desperate
for money that he hires two thugs to
kidnap his own wife jerry will collect
the ransom from her wealthy father
paying the thugs a small portion and
keeping the rest to satisfy his debts
this scheme collapses when the thugs
shoot a state trooper starring francis
mcdormand steve buscemi william h macy
and directed by joel cohen critics say
violent quirky and darkly funny fargo
delivers an original crime story and a
wonderful performance by mcdormand
mr londigard huh yeah
could i take just a minute of your time
here what what is it all about huh do
you mind if i sit down carrying quite a
load here
you're the owner here mr londyguard nye
executive sales manager well you can
help me my name's marge gundra my
father-in-law he's the owner
uh-huh
well i'm a police officer from brainerd
investigating some malfeasance and i was
just wondering if you'd had any new
vehicles stolen off the lot in the past
couple of weeks
specifically at tan color sierra
mr londegaard
brainerd
yeah yeah
homer paul bunyan babe the blue wax
babe the blue hawks
yeah you know we got that big statue up
there
so
you haven't had any vehicles going
missing then nope no ma'am
okey-dokey thanks a bunch i'll let you
get back to your paperwork then
number four goodwill hunting
will hunting has a genius level iq but
chooses to work as a janitor at mit when
he solves a difficult graduate level
math problem his talents are discovered
by professor gerald lambeau who decides
to help the misguided youth reach his
potential when will is arrested for
attacking a police officer professor
lambeau makes a deal to get leniency for
him if he will get treatment from
therapist sean mcguire starring matt
damon robin williams ben affleck and
directed by gus van sant critics say it
follows a predictable narrative arc but
good will hunting adds enough quirks to
the journey and is loaded with enough
powerful performances that it remains in
entertaining emotionally rich drama
i was just hoping you might give me some
insight into the evolution of the market
economy in the southern colonies
my contention is that uh prior to the
revolutionary war
the economic modalities especially in
the southern colonies
could most aptly be characterized as
agrarian pre-capital right of course
that's you
you're a first-year grad student you
just got finished reading some moxie and
historian pete garrison probably you're
gonna be convinced of that till next
month when you get to james lemon then
you're going to be talking about how the
economies of virginia and pennsylvania
were entrepreneurial and capitalists way
back in 1740. that's going to last until
next year you're going to be in here
regurgitating gordon wood talking about
you know the pre-revolutionary utopia
and the capital farming effects of
military mobilization
well as a matter of fact i won't because
wood drastically underestimates the
impact would you like social media to do
it drastically underestimates the impact
of social distinctions predicated upon
wealth especially inherited wealthy
you got that from vickers work in essex
county page 98 right
yeah i read that too were you going to
plagiarize the whole thing for us do you
have any thoughts
of your own on this matter
number three schindler's list
businessman oscar schindler arrives in
krakow in 1939 ready to make his fortune
from world war ii which has just started
after joining the nazi party primarily
for political expediency he staffs his
factory with jewish workers for
similarly pragmatic reasons when the ss
begins exterminating jews in the krakow
ghetto schindler arranges to have his
workers protected to keep his factory in
operation but soon realizes that in
doing so he is also saving innocent
lives starring liam neeson ben kingsley
ray finds and directed by steven
spielberg critics say schindler's list
blends the abject horror of the
holocaust with steven spielberg's
signature tender humanism to create the
director's dramatic masterpiece
what
did god
say about this you just told him how
many people you needed
[Music]
if you are still working for me i'd
expect you to talk me out of it it's
costing me
finish the page and leave one space at
the bottom
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the list is an absolute good
the list
is life
all around
its margins lies the gulf
number two la confidential
three policemen each with his own
motives and obsessions tackle the
corruption surrounding an unsolved
murder at a downtown la coffee shop in
the early 1950s detective lieutenant
exley the son of a murder detective is
out to avenge his father's killing the
ex-partner of officer white implicated
in a scandal rooted out by exley was one
of the victims and sergeant jack feeds
classified information to a tabloid
magnate starring russell crowe guy
pierce james cromwell and directed by
curtis hanson critics say top pacing
brilliantly dense writing and
oscar-worthy acting combined to produce
a smart popcorn friendly thrill ride in
la confidential
come on don't pull that good cop bad cop
crap i practically invented it
so what if some homo actor is dead huh
boys girls 10 of them get off the bus to
la every day
[Music]
now i know you think you're the number
one hot shot but here's the juice if i
take you out ten more lawyers will take
your place tomorrow they just won't come
on the bus
[Music]
all right okay
okay
hey oh oh my god i wouldn't play ball so
they set me up and then i gave in but
the kid hurt everything
oh so they killed him why
what are dudley and pat's it up to
they're taking over mickey contracts
because because of those pictures i i
could i couldn't prosecute them oh jesus
[Music]
is that how you used to run the good cop
bad cop
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the matrix
neo believes that morpheus an elusive
figure considered to be the most
dangerous man alive can answer his
question what is the matrix neo is
contacted by trinity a beautiful
stranger who leads him into an
underworld where he meets morpheus they
fight a brutal battle for their lives
against a cadre of viciously intelligent
secret agents it is a truth that could
cost neo something more precious than
his life starring keanu reeves lawrence
fishburne carrie anne moss and directed
by lily and lana wachowski critics say
thanks to the wachowski's imaginative
vision the matrix is a smartly crafted
combination of spectacular action and
groundbreaking special effects
[Music]
[Music]
trinity
help
[Music]
oh
dodge this
the shawshank redemption
andy dufresne is sentenced to two
consecutive life terms in prison for the
murders of his wife and her lover and is
sentenced to a tough prison however only
andy knows he didn't commit the crimes
while there he forms a friendship with
red experiences brutality of prison life
adapts helps a warden etc all in 19
years starring tim robbins morgan
freeman bob gunton and directed by frank
derebon critics say the shawshank
redemption is an uplifting deeply
satisfying prison drama with sensitive
direction and fine performances step
aside mert this fucker's having himself
an accident he'll push him off the roof
because if you do trust it there's no
reason you can't keep that 35 000.
what did you say 35 000. 35 000. all of
it all of it every penny
you better start making sense if you
want to keep all that money give it to
your wife the irs allows a one-time only
gift to your spouse for up to sixty
thousand dollars oh [ __ ] tax-free
tax-free irs can't touch one cent
yeah that smart banker would kill his
wife aren't you why should i believe a
smart banker like you so i can end up in
here with you it's perfectly legal go
ask the rs they'll say the same thing
actually i feel stupid telling you this
i'm sure you would have investigated
them out of yourself yeah [ __ ] a i
don't need no smart wife killing banker
to tell me where the bears hitting the
buckwheat of course not but you do need
someone to set up the tax rate gift for
you that'll cost you a lawyer for
example a bunch of ball washing
all right
i suppose i could set it up for you that
would save you some money
if you get the forms i'll prepare them
for you
nearly free of charge
i'd only ask three beers a piece for
each of my co-workers
co-workers get him that's rich ain't it
i think a man working outdoors feels
more like a man if you're gonna have a
bottle of suds
it's only my opinion
sir and before we get to number one here
is another honorable mention
pulp fiction
jules and vincent are hitmen with a
penchant for philosophical discussions
in this ultra hit multi-strand crime
movie their storyline is interwoven with
those of their boss gangster marcellus
wallace his wife mia struggling boxer
butch coolidge master fixer winston wolf
and a nervous pair of armed robbers
pumpkin and honey bunny starring john
travolta samuel l jackson uma thurman
and directed by quentin tarantino
critics say one of the most influential
films of the 1990s pulp fiction is a
delirious postmodern mix of neo-noir
thrills pitch black humor and pop
culture touchstones
see
i got the idea
the last liquor store we stuck up
remember
all the customers kept coming in
yeah
you got the idea of taking their wallets
now that was a good idea
thank you made more from a while it's
been different register yes we did
a lot of people come to restaurants
pretty smart huh
pretty smart
i'm ready let's do it right now right
here
come on all right
same as last time remember
your crowd control my hand employees
[Music]
i love you honey bunny
everybody be cool this is a robbery
and finally number one toy story
woody a good-hearted cowboy doll who
belongs to a young boy named andy sees
his position as andy's favorite toy
jeopardized when his parents buy him a
buzz lightyear action figure even worse
the arrogant buzz thinks he's a real
spaceman on a mission to return to his
home planet when andy's family moves to
a new house woody and buzz must escape
the clutches of maladjusted neighbor sid
phillips and reunite with their boy
starring tom hanks tim allen don rickles
and directed by john lasseter critics
say entertaining as it is innovative toy
story reinvigorated animation while
heralding the arrival of pixar as a
family-friendly force to be reckoned
with
[Music]
okay come on kids
everyone in the living room
[Music]
oh
[Music]
and this
is how we find out what is in those
presents
[Music]
okay
who's hungry
here comes the chips i've got cool ranch
and barbecue
what in the world
i thought i told him to pick these up
shouldn't they be there by now what's
taking them so long hey these guys are
professionals they're the best
come on they're not lying down on the
job
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and until
next time i'm your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you